Hey Youtubers, it's Charlie
touch of death, so we have to talk
about teeing up the black flash on the flash
is also legends of tomorrow stuff that will
address this to there's so many DC things
that are happening during the week.
I'll add links in the description just so
everybody doesn't miss the videos that I'm
posting but be sure to subscribe to get everything
there is a new round of the flash ring giveaway
that I'm going to be announcing in my legends
video that I'll post a couple hours.
So be sure to click that bell to enable alerts
so you don't miss anything.
The really cool thing that's going on in this
is they're introducing a character called
Clive Yorkin he has very black flash like
powers so it's going to tee up the idea of
the black flash draining the life force from
people like live your can touch is something
it turns to ash.
That's part of something called the nephron
process in the comics so he's this mentally
deranged person gets locked up in iron Heights,
because he's found near the dead body of Iris
West.
This is way back during the silver age.
During the original Barry Allen comics in
way later in the comics after a crisis on
infinite earths he showed up in a Wally West
title inside iron Heights right before a big
gorilla Grodd battle with the flash the Wally
West version of the flash Barry Allen was
still gone at this time is like way back I
think it was around 2004.
When this dropped but the funny thing is is
that in real life the gorilla city episode
is getting ready to happen.
After this episode.
Even though there's a break and the flash
next week there's not supposed to be a new
episode but all remind people about the schedule
as we go along.
So the whole idea here is that they have to
find a way to defeat him without touching
him.
So it's important for black flash fights later
on because you can't let the black flash touch
you but it's also important for saving Iris
from savitar because you have to be fast enough
like Wally says at the end of the episode
I'm not fast enough.
So you probably noticed that they'll tee up
smaller ideas in early episodes that will
teach the hero a lesson or give them some
information that will help him later on when
he's fighting the big bad you may notice last
year that Barry went back in time and was
talking to himself.
He learned about time wraiths, nursing one
that is in time wraiths stated speedsters
naturally timeline another thing to do everything
it can't and you
use that information during the season finale
when he was fighting zoom who is now the black
flash, so I'll be doing a video for legends
of tomorrow next all explained that, to try
something a little bit different right just
pick out like that crazy scene and then do
WTF moments so that will post in a little
while but the whole idea here is that their
training Wally Wally has to learn these lessons.
This is all from the Wally West era of the
comics, so whole bunch of Wally happening
in the back half of the season.
A lot of you been asking, especially after
the last episode if they're going to push
grant Gustin out as Barry Allen but Barry
Allen will die and Wally West will take over
as the flash just like they did in the comics
so the thing about the flash is is that they
all signed seven year contracts and grant
Gustin is always going to be the main version
of the flash there might be brief periods
where he goes away and Wally has to step up
for may be like a single episode, so I'm expecting
them to tease that idea at some point, but
the show is it such of a bummer that it would
make you think that the flash is never going
to come back they did the same thing with
the Oliver Queen character on arrow where
they kill them off seemingly but your like
oh my got Stephen Amell is the lead of the
show where they going to do if there's no
arrow on arrow anymore they have to bring
them back.
So literally in the next episode he woke up,
so to speak, so they let you know that he
was still alive so anytime the flash does
something like that they usually don't let
it sit for too long to let you know what's
going to happen.
Like when Barry got sucked into the speed
force in everybody thought he was dead really
he just been turned into pure energy he was
visiting the speedster version of heaven.
So will learn more about that the season must
you know about the speed force source like
our space or just a no the first subatomic
particle spring force from the Big Bang to
form reality as you know in the with her when
the last proton decays stuff vibrating and
plunges the universe and to keep this will
be there to talking to the speed force is
in that conversation with graphic like, so
there might be a time when he gets stuck in
the speed force for brief.
Between seasons.
I don't know if they would actually be as
bold, to try something like that but you guys
can let me know, this episode seems like it's
a lot more about him than about anything else
do you think the river going to do in episode
where it seems like Barry said.
So Wally steps up for brief.
When Barry comes back because there been a
couple times that happened in the comics there
was even a really cool reverse flash story
during the Mark Wade era where Barry Allen
came back from the dead, only to find out
that it was secretly eobard Thawne masquerading
as Barry Allen so this a whole bunch reverse
flash stuff happening a legends of tomorrow
will talk about that when I post that video,
but I'm really hoping for a couple of big
twist with the end of legends of tomorrow
because they're having all the speedsters
stuff going on.
There's the Spear of destiny.
So if you guys are watching that make sure
you start watching that because the way it's
going right now is I'll post in my flash videos
Tuesday nights then I post in the trailer
video then I post legends of tomorrow and
then the arrow video, so hopefully, you guys
are able to find the videos okay as long as
you have alerts enabled for my channel you'll
see the videos when I post them every once
in a while it takes a little while for those
to roll out YouTube breaks a little bit, but
you can always go straight to my channel page
the videos tab just to see what I've been
posting, but it's gonna be great.
I'll be naming the flash ring giveaway winner
when I post that legends video in a couple
hours.
So be sure to check that out while you wait
for that you can click here for the flash
video and you can click here for legends I'll
update the link as soon as I post it, thank
you so much watching everybody high five I'll
see you in the next video!